I know my game is
on
cigarette she's getting up lunch
Oh No I'm freaking out arde
I'm not a racer what am i my best friend
all I gotta do is find a park to fix the
game everything goes back to meet you do
wanna get rich playing video games
slaughter race he's wicked dangerous
yeah attention to details pretty
impressive
well well well who are you I think we
should get out of here
Showtime that's right
love you know there's so many babies and
cats in the world
I want this to be my life
I don't think I could ever tell her Alf
there's no law saying best friends have
to have the same dreams
[Music]
this is what's called the darknet are
you sure this is safe just whatever you
do do not look at his little brother
little brother what are you doing huh
hmm
the reason I came to your neck of the
face I mean there's a face in your neck
I mean woods neck of the woods
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ] I don't think we're lit wax anymore
[Music]
holy cow look at all this stuff
this is the most beautiful miracle I've
ever seen forever and ever
I'm sure there's someone out here to
give us directions he's got more of
those hats at smart people where I bet
he could help us come on I'm sure
there's someone out here could give us
directions oh hey guy he's got more of
those hats at smart people where I bet
he could help us come on oh hello sir
interesting you don't seem to have a
search history well let's start one for
you what can knows more I help you find
today ah umbrella umbrage Oh mommy no no
is art no doubt
no it's from economics urban outfitters
or cool looks like no one put Humpty
Dumpty together again this guy's a
little soft boil guess what you're gonna
say yes I'm sorry but my autofill is a
touch aggressive today let me try eBay
sugar rush steering wheel I only found
one result for your query
isn't that interesting it's very
intuitive thank you mister knows more
well you're welcome
this is the guy who this man was the
undulating jowls
so grab him a drink yeah this lady named
shank she actually made the video she's
the one who told us to come see you no
wonder your video so don't shake is for
real cool right she is not I'm the cool
one getting all the hearts you big baby
Ralph wreck-it Ralph well wicked Ralph
you are trending and these are for you
lady
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I believe you have something of mine
[Music]
[Music]
wanna get rich play video games only
slaughterous it is wicked dangerous oh
yeah I think we should get out here
this car is not designed for a big boy
Oh contrived
I give my mommy a key she turned into a
big beer oh it didn't try to do then is
no pure mace I don't know where he can't
understand her she's from the other
studio ah well there's not one thing
about your life you would change
nope I was very excited to get back in
the saddle on this one Ralph and
vanellope are best friends in the arcade
and because the steering wheel of
vanilla peas game breaks Oh suddenly
Ralph and vanellope have to figure out
oh how do we get this Park to fix their
game everything goes back to the way it
was look Ralph loves predictable days
the internet scares him because it
disrupts what is normal for him Scotty
right now we're vanilla P craves
excitement want to get rich playing
video games slaughtering he's wicked
dangerous Showtime
let's race shank is played by a gal
gadot she is the leader of this racing
game which is thrilling to vanellope
wasn't change the coolest person you
ever mattered and cool friend about it
looks cool as drives cool her hair is
cooler car is Chloe's me you see my hair
isn't cool Ralph wreck-it Ralph well you
are trending yes is the head algorithm
of a very popular website called buzz -
who knew there's so many babies and cats
in the world
vanellope starts to steal I've been
living this sort of preschool classroom
I could be out at college they're always
learning and growing and their
experiences with the good and bad it
changes both of them forever there is no
law saying best friends have to have the
same dreams we came here to save your
game and that's what we're gonna do
I told you this place was a good idea
[Music]
start churning butter and put on your
church shoes little sister cuz we're
about to blast off what is it you're
trying to say we're going the Internet
[Music]
[Music]
this is the most beautiful miracle I've
ever seen
welcome to the search bar what can I
help you find today Oh umbrella umbrage
Oh mommy no no is that no doubt
Nordstrom Rack economics Urban
Outfitters you're cool I'm pretty sure
he's just trying to guess what you're
gonna say my auto failure to touch
aggressive today let me try
take me to a website that's super
intense and really nuts boom I'd only
found one result
come on cartoon characters barb
come with us kid
ladies I'm a princess - what kind of a
princess are you huh do you have magic
hair no magic hands
no do animals talk to you know who are
you Paul is no cursed no kidnapped or
enslave no are you guys okay please do
people assume all your problems got
solved because a big strong man showed
up the Internet shouldn't be rough Rex
the Internet
yes since he is wreckit-ralph uh yeah
but break the Internet it's like a thing
right it's just wreck seeing it kind of
sounds better doesn't it you're not
wrong what do you say your name was
Ralph wreck-it Ralph all four of us grew
up on Disney I love it so it's such a
timeless incredible opportunity to be a
part of vector alpha brawling we are
shooting in Miami Florida it is like a
very vital Cade slash dungeon let's call
it a fun gin a pungent we're gonna fund
you
you would've thought to be a zebra oz4
the song's called zero it personifies
feeling like a loner and an outsider at
times and learning to navigate what that
means your luck you have to get David
Myers to do this video I'd say be Dave
Meyer he's Dave Myers when we saw that
he was interested in doing this video we
were all blown away because this is work
in the past especially the stuff with
Kendrick I think is maybe the best video
I've ever seen period play a counter
clerk people come in and lord over
people Lord oh the game doesn't work no
I think the song has a really special
energy to it there's something frantic
and almost manic it's probably the most
up-tempo song I think we've ever written
to date right fastest tempo yeah only
for Disney emotion captured in the film
we reached out to all of us and we all
related to it in the way that it felt
very natural to be able to write a song
[Music]
[Music]
all right let's get you plugged in
Withey or is it wifey i don't we just go
in and we are online
we are going to the super-excited
there's one minor thing what is the
internet holy cow look at all this stuff
in detail stars like the prison number
six will amaze you
redirected to ebay ladies and gentlemen
the next item up a black velvet painting
in a sorrowful kitten it's like it's
looking into my soul yeah that one's
really gonna haunt me for a while
[Music]
thank you go see good see I don't
understand why people like this game
raised in Boots it up pick it pick it
pick the kitty for a little Maya
no the kitty gets the milkshake the
bunny
[Music]